[Music]
at last I've uncovered the secrets of
what it means to be a Disney princess
behold princess hat the first theorist
princess according to last week's
episode I have everything I need
I've got my royal fury dress which is
very highly merchandising Bowl to the
four-year-olds I've got myself my sassy
animal sidekick and I've got a can-do
attitude
Disneyland soundsational parade here I
come not so fast
haha I told you once and I'll tell you
again you'll never be a business s what
what do you mean Mouse I did everything
you said
I called the shots around here pal and
you'll never make it into my exclusive
princess room wait the random room
labeled princesses in the trailer for
wreck-it Ralph - yeah eat it
but that's so arbitrary why does being
in a room in a completely separate movie
qualify you as a princess you'll never
know because you'll never make the cut
watch has all those dreams of being a
pretty pretty princess wither and die
and I suck on those sweet salty tears
you're you're insane insanely wealthy
you mean mouth you're no Mouse at all I
know what you are now you're just a rat
just a dirty dirty rats
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that continues to be a royal
pain to the Disney Canon by uncovering
the double standards in princess
selection now if you haven't seen the
first part of the series click here to
make sure that you're all caught up as
we set off on a quest to determine what
makes a princess truly a Disney Princess
this time we concluded that you don't
need to be heroic chosen by fate you
don't need to be able to sing heck you
don't even need to be a princess in
Disney's eyes being a princess is all
about what you're wearing you dress ie
anything that can be sold at the bibbidi
bobbidi boutique in Disneyland oh and
you also need an animal sidekick and
that's it that's all there is to it with
an automatic disqualification if you
might be mistaken as a prostitute but
after figuring all of that out we still
have to come back to why I started doing
these episodes in the first place to
figure out whether vanellope von
schweetz from wreck-it ralph would
qualify as Disney's newest princess or
at the very least whether she deserves
to be in the Disney Princess room that
shown in wreck-it Ralph two's trailer
you see last time we looked at what has
historically qualified a character as a
Disney Princess but the princess room in
the trailer appears to be an updated
Disney Princess roster one that's more
open and more inclusive or not but
there's only one way to find out so
let's get ourselves into the throne room
where it happened to find out for
ourselves what qualifies you as a Disney
princess in the world of wreck-it Ralph
- and whether vanellope might be the
newest addition to the Disney Princess
lineup so first who are the Disney
Princesses of wreck-it Ralph - well
looking at the trailers we can identify
jasmine Snow White Cinderella Pocahontas
Penelope Elsa and Anna Moana Belle
Rapunzel Merida Ariel Aurora Tiana and
Mulan interestingly enough this doesn't
line up with the official list of Disney
Princesses that we covered last time
Anna Elsa and Moana have all gotten
upgraded for this particular movie but
even with this expanded roster there are
a few notable snobs from Hercules as
Megan hunchbacks Esmeralda - princess a
lonely from Black Cauldron and kita from
Atlantis the lost Empire so just like
last time we have to deduce what
separates the princesses inside the room
from those out
the room to back to our way into the
requirements for getting in which will
in turn allow us to determine if
vanellope truly meets all the criteria
now the fact that Milan's in the room
already eliminates the requirement of
being an actual princess ie the daughter
of a monarch or the wife of a prince as
we covered last time Mulan for as cool
as she is never actually assumes
princess status even still it's worth
mentioning that Penelope is a princess
in her own game it is literally written
into her code so even if this was a
requirement wealth she would definitely
qualify on that front once inside the
room the princesses toss out a few lines
that are less qualifications for
princess status and more tongue-in-cheek
jokes at Disney's expense kidnap to
enslave no are you guys Rapunzel asks if
nella P has magic hair but obviously
that shouldn't qualify someone as a
princess because Rapunzel is the only
person in the room with magic hair
unless you count Pocahontas is perpetual
breeze blowing on her so epic Elsa asks
about magic hands but again it's the
same problem here
Elle says the only one with those funny
enough even though vanellope answer's no
to a lot of these questions she actually
qualifies for a bunch of them I mean
think about it does she have a magic
power yeah in her first movie she has
the power to glitch a power that she
hones throughout the film and figures
out how to control at the end so she can
defeat the villain and reclaim her
throne huh why does that sound familiar
oh yeah was vanellope cursed I mean she
says no in the trailer but yeah her code
was tampered with in wreck-it Ralph so
she could be removed from the throne and
placed into total obscurity for a long
period of time and if that doesn't sound
familiar to you well then maybe you
should re-watch tangled or Sleeping
Beauty already just based on those
things vanellope is scoring higher on
the princess meter than most of the
ladies in the room which actually puts
her in pretty good position to become
the next addition to the Disney Princess
lineup but we can't make this call based
on a few random qualifications thrown
out in the trailer we need to find
something that truly unites everyone we
see in this room and disqualifies
everyone that we don't see in the room
so the next logical thing is to look at
the end of the scene here Rapunzel asks
if people all think that vanilla pees
problems are solved by a big strong man
when actually they weren't when
vanellope says yeah what's up with that
it's the punchline that confirms that
vanellope really is a disney princess
after all
now last episode I gave the girls a hard
I'm about this because guess what
Arielle both Triton and Prince Eric are
forced to clean up your little mess and
save all of Atlantica
how about complaining less about other
people stealing your achievements and
instead stepping up and owning your
mistakes that would be a good moral
lesson sour grapes aside this seriously
can't be the qualifier for this room I
mean sure the older princesses in the
room were indeed rescued by dudes who
went around kissing unconscious women in
the forest but what about these ladies
it's awfully hard to argue that people
think that the new guard of Disney
princesses need a man when they're
movies specifically feature them
flipping this narrative on its head one
of the most central themes of Moana is
that a character like Maui literally the
archetype of the big strong man is not
the linchpin in the story this theme is
even more apparent in frozen where
Disney intentionally takes the idea of
love and Princess movies and flips it
around by making the handsome prince the
ultimate villain love doesn't have to be
romantic love in fact the strongest love
is with your sister it's actually a
really nice message realtalk know we got
super sick of frozen there for a while
because it was so overexposed everywhere
but seriously if we all take a moment to
take off our jaded glasses it's a really
good movie with some really good music
and honestly it was really ballsy for
Disney to do all that being said is this
room arbitrary is it just Disney giving
up and randomly including some new
popular princesses to keep everyone from
complaining of course not
this is Disney we're talking about they
are way too smart for that
no the Disney princess room and wreck-it
Ralph too doesn't come down to looks or
animal friends or not need no man nope
it's not about who they are it's about
what they earn the qualification for
Disney Princesses in this room comes
down to how much Bank they can roll in
for Disney if you don't believe me check
out the stats websites like Box Office
Mojo keep track of gross profits from
movies going all the way back to the
earliest classics like gone with the
wind and snow white and even accounts
for ticket price inflation now this lets
us compare how deep the Royal coffers go
for each of the Disney Princesses that
we see here and it tells us a pretty
clear story about what makes Disney
treat a woman like royalty versus giving
them the Royal dude out of the Magic
Kingdom looking at all the global gross
adjusted profits for Disney Princess
movies there are no surprises at the top
of the list with fros
being the first modern Disney princess
movie to gross over 1 billion dollars
globally with a single release that 1
billion dollars apparently buys you two
seats in the Disney Princess room the
rest of the princess's score between six
hundred and seventy three million
dollars globally with Sleeping Beauty
down all the way to the low end of
Princess and the Frog with two hundred
and sixty seven million dollars globally
and 104 million dollars specifically in
the US and wouldn't you know it but that
seems to be our cutoff anything that
falls below the 250 million dollar range
for worldwide gross profits or under a
hundred million dollars in US profits no
longer makes the cutoff for entry into
this room it's the one thing that
reliably separates the snubs from this
room
Hercules it only made 99 million dollars
in the u.s. so afraid meg isn't getting
past the bouncer punch back also in the
low hundred million dollar range
domestically and again Esmeralda kinda
treated like prostitute Black Cauldron
and Atlantis both Disney movies
featuring empowered female princesses
fall even further below the cutoff so
nope they don't stand a chance
remember the Disney Princess merchandise
brand makes over 1.5 billion dollars
every single year so if these gals can't
push ticket sales to their movies then
you know they're not worthy to sip
lattes with the rest of the gals and you
know sell dresses tiaras and dolls off
the shelves as an aside I got to point
this out each princess wearing her
signature pajamas at that slumber party
is obviously the most blatant commercial
for Disney apparel that I have ever seen
but then again we on the internet
apparently don't care by the way
theorist merch is still on sale go get
yourself a t-shirt they're great they're
comfortable you're gonna look amazing so
there you have it you women of Disney
are only worth what you're able to earn
that's gotta be worse than the messaging
last episode I mean think about it
Disney is clearly pandering to your
strong female pride in this trailer but
for all the girl power that's present
here they're not practicing what they
preach the girls in this room aren't
here because of their heroism they're
here because of money Disney's bottom
line if inclusion in the princess room
was truly about strong women who don't
need no man well then you would see less
financially viable characters here but
they're not they are kept outside of
Disney's
you'd shiny blockbusters swept under the
rug alongside Dumbo's Jim crows so that
you'll forget about them Disney's
failures and move on and buy yet another
shiny princess dress but with that said
now that we've found the crucial
differentiator basically that all our
princesses are major one-percenters for
Disney we can finally decide if
vanellope belongs in the room or not
based on the gross adjusted global
profits for the first of wreck-it Ralph
movie he turned four hundred and seventy
one point two million dollars which
definitely qualifies vanellope for the
rich princess club in the US alone it
raked in almost a hundred ninety million
dollars beating out other princesses in
the room like Mulan and tiana and
thereby securing vanellope a spot at the
slumber party she'll even represent a
new category of princess dig deep
princess
actually no because Princess Leia would
also qualify for the room and she would
probably be the geek princess maybe the
star princess all she has no animal
sidekick Leia would be in this room but
as an official Disney princess based on
qualifications last time she wouldn't be
anyway Penelope at the very least would
be like the gamer princess so there you
have it based on the qualifications
required to get into the princess room
vanellope does indeed qualify as a
Disney princess and as long as record
Ralph too performs at the box office she
shouldn't get the boot right Wow it had
been a month ago I would have said yes
however there might be one more wrinkle
to this that puts Penelope's place in
the princess Hall of Fame in jeopardy it
has to do with Disney's latest actions
not towards their princesses but towards
their employees you see in a recent
controversy Disney chose to fire the
director of the guardians of the galaxy
movies James Gunn over a series of
vulgar and inappropriate tweets that he
made between 2009 and 2011 and having
read those tweets let me make it clear
they're really bad especially as they
relate to women and kids which if your
Disney you're gonna be kind of sensitive
about I'm not gonna put them here out of
fear of the kids who watch a video about
wreck-it Ralph and Disney Princesses but
I am gonna put the link in the
description so that you can read them
and judge for yourselves which you
should do in any sort of circumstance
like this read the information for
yourself and make your own call a lot of
stuff gets mixed up with misinformation
anyway even though James Gunn deleted
the tweets and apologized for a multiple
times in the intervening years Disney's
stated that quote the offensive
attitudes and statements discovered
James's Twitter feed are indefensible
and inconsistent with our studios values
and we have severed our business
relationship with him end quotes if this
is Disney's policy with its employees
though they're gonna start running into
some issues with other employees in this
case old vanellope von schweetz voiced
by Sarah Silverman you see just like
Gunn and quite honestly like a lot of
comedians Sarah's early work really
double down on edgy envelope-pushing
humor taking controversial taboo topics
and diving headfirst into them for
example her show on Comedy Central the
Sarah Silverman program had full
episodes dedicated to jokes like
blackface and sexual deviants she's used
racial slurs before on late-night
programs and has actively said that she
wanted to be the first person to make
jokes at the expense of Martin Luther
King jr. all things that seem fairly
comparable to what Gunn did on his
Twitter feed and just like guns Sarah
Silverman has apologized and made it
clear that she's embarrassed by a lot of
those early jokes of hers now I'm not
casting judgment here I report facts and
from those concoct theories I have no
problems with Sarah and I think that
she's done a lot of good for a lot of
really positive causes and I firmly
believe that humor acceptable taste and
most importantly people change over time
but with the James Gunn situation Disney
has set itself a precedent it's they're
currently being hotly debated in social
media none of us have a copy of Disney's
code of conduct in front of them but if
the nella P is truly contributing to the
Disney princess powerhouse we all might
want to be prepared for a little change
of voice acting just in case but hey
that's just a theory a film theory you
think wreck-it Ralph breaks the Internet
that is nothing compared to
wreckit-ralph sub the real world people
who actually want to break into stuff on
the Internet including people's accounts
phones and computers King candy the
hacker of the original wreck-it Ralph is
creepy enough even bet that real
internet hackers aren't nearly gonna be
a sweet so what do you do to stop them
well you use a VPN like I do and like a
lot of my other fellow youtubers do and
the one that I found the best results
with is our sponsor for today nor
VPN you could say that it protects the
royal treasury of my film theory scripts
now if you've never used a VPN before
Nord is a great place to start because
it's easy to use and you can install it
across all your different devices
whether it's the phone that you play
fix-it felix on a tablet you write your
Disney fanfiction on or the desktop
where you complain in the comments that
my theories are bogus on hashtag get map
pad off the internet no matter what
you're doing you'll be doing it safely
through Nord which filters all the data
coming in and out of your computer on
the internet making it a lot harder for
someone to hack you or for other
malicious stuff to happen to your
devices I mean seriously it's a lot of
peace of mind because it's basically
like your own personal internet filter
on a more serious note as someone who
just became a dad and has a baby monitor
running on my Wi-Fi you can bet that
Internet security has a whole new
meaning for me now but regardless of
whatever information you're looking to
protect the websites you're visiting
your personal account information
whatever your reason for wanting to be
safer and more protected online check
out Nord VPN with the link in the
description click it down there or head
to north VPN comm slash film theory and
ord VPN comm / fil mthe o ry where
they're giving away a huge discount off
their subscriptions with our code
seriously it is huge it is 77 percent
off which is kind of a random number but
it still a massive random number it's
like almost giving it away for free so
go there now because it's ending soon
stay out of King Candy's clutches nor
DPN